[MUSIC PLAYING]
WHITLEY TALMADGE:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Whitley Talmadge.
And today, I will be
talking about Dialogflow.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
I'm Whitley Talmadge.
I am a customer engineer
for Google Cloud.
And I will be talking
about how to build
conversational experiences with
Dialogflow using Google Cloud
Platform today.
So I'll be providing a brief
overview of Dialogflow,
Google's conversation engine,
and a preview of our upcoming
Coursera course called Building
Conversational Experiences
With Dialogflow.
I'll demonstrate some of the
basic features of Dialogflow
in a few Google Cloud Platform
products using the Qwiklabs
platform.
I'll go over the
free training offers
we have available as part
of this session to get
you hands-on with Dialogflow.
And as I mentioned, we'll also
be answering the questions
that you submit.
In this course, we
take a look at how
to build engaging conversational
experiences using Dialogflow.
We start off by using
Dialogflow's building blocks
to create an agent step by
step by defining user intents,
extracting potential
entities, maintaining
the context of the
conversation, as well as being
able to perform fulfillment
actions outside of Dialogflow--
for example, storing data
pieces from the conversation
into a database.
We have plenty of
demos that walk you
through each of
these steps and then
have you do the same through
a series of hands-on labs,
at the end of which you get
to test out your chatbot.
Next, we discuss
a number of themes
that are important
when you want to take
your chatbot to
production, like being
able to add basic
authentication,
customizing your
chatbot's UI, deploying
fulfillment code on scalable
serverless architecture,
and leveraging existing sources
to automate parts of a agent
building process.
Towards the end of
the course, we also
talk about how to integrate
your chatbot into other channels
or surfaces, like
the Google Assistant.
And we also touch on a few
other additional functionalities
that can make your agents
smarter and even more engaging.
To achieve the learning
objectives discussed,
the Building
Conversational Experiences
With Dialogflow course consists
of these five modules--
building conversational
experiences with Dialogflow,
defining intents and
entities, maintaining context
and taking action,
taking your chatbot
to production, and
additional functionality.
Conversational experience is the
descriptive comprehensive name
for a new class
of solutions that
include chatbots, conversational
apps, and other similar terms.
Dialogflow is a tool
that can help you build
smart conversational agents.
Dialogflow is an end to
end developer platform
for building natural and rich
conversational experiences.
At its core, Dialogflow is
a powerful natural language
understanding engine to
process and understand
natural language input.
In other words,
it lets you easily
achieve a conversational
user experience
by handling the natural
language understanding for you.
Using Dialogflow, you can build
conversational experiences
faster, engage end
users more efficiently,
and maximize reach across
geographies and platforms.
By leveraging these capabilities
and what the developer provides
as input training
data, Dialogflow
creates unique algorithms for
each specific conversational
agent under the hood, which
continuously learns and is
tweaked for you as more and more
users engage with your agent.
Some conversational agents
exist for very specific, very
simple use cases with few
intents and minimal dependency
on communicating with back end
systems or knowledge bases,
while some have multiple
intents dealing with more
complex domains and back ends.
But typically, the workflow to
get your conversational agent
up and running maps out
to these three phases--
design, what to build, develop,
how to build, and deploy,
how to deliver.
Keep the style
guide in mind as you
design your agents responses.
For the best user
experience, you probably
don't want your agent to
sound too formal or robotic.
For example, to make your
agent more reminiscent
of actual human conversation,
you might have it say something
like, does that sound good?
Rather than something like--
if you feel you have reached
this message in error.
Creating your Dialogflow
agent all starts with intents.
Intents are the trunk
of the dialog tree.
They connect all
of the branches.
Intense determine where
a conversation will go
and what an agent should do.
In communication,
intents can be thought
of as the root verbs
in the conversation,
such as wanting
coffee translating
to acquiring a beverage.
Sometimes the intents are
not explicit and instead
are inferred from the entire
composition of a phrase.
You want to map your intents to
the goal of your application.
If you are a help
desk application,
then your intents might include
opening and filing a ticket,
updating a ticket,
and closing a ticket.
But your application
may also need
to access and update a
user's account information,
branch over to a
live technician,
and even pass along a
quality assurance survey.
Even affirmation, answering
yes or no, is an intent.
Intents evolve as
your understanding
of the user's needs evolves.
And you may find yourself
doubling or tripling
your intents beyond your
initial set of intents.
To make the task of
defining intents easier,
some rules of thumb
can be applied.
First, identify the verbs
in the dialogue people
will have with your agent.
Doing that will allow your
agent to have its actions
mapped to needs from the user.
Another possible scenario is to
identify where the application
should branch logic.
Here are some examples.
Two mocha coffees, please.
How many calories in a slice?
I want a pizza.
Or even, I really
need some caffeine.
Once you have
chosen your intents,
you need to train your
agent to recognize them.
This can be done with the
use of training phrases.
The training phrases
for each intent
should be representative of
how users will say the intent.
It is always a good
idea to add variations
to the grammatical
construction of a request,
such as passive
versus active voices
or questions versus statements.
This will help represent
the variety of ways
a user might say an intent.
When creating an intent,
the more training
phrases you can
think of, the better.
Later, we will
discuss best practices
for writing your
training phrases.
Entities help you get to the
specifics of an interaction.
In dialogue, the entities
are the nouns or quantifiers
found through the conversation,
such as a person's name,
the food in a review of a
cruise, specific numbers
or dates just to name a few.
When you are creating an
entity and you identify
that the entity
contains attributes
that you need to map to, one way
is to use composite entities.
For our ordering pizza
example, let's say
that we want to create an
intent for ordering pizza.
A pizza could be of type
regular or thin crust.
Regular and thin
crust, in this case,
both are entries in an
entity called pizza.
System entities are pre-built
entities provided by Dialogflow
in order to facilitate handling
the most popular concepts.
Use one of the system
entities to represent
date and time, for
example, or others
such as addresses,
currency, units, numbers,
and many others.
Contexts allow the agent to
keep track of where the user is
at in the conversation.
In the context of
Dialogflow, they
are also a means for an
application to store and access
variables mentioned
in the dialog.
In this example
of ordering pizza,
if the sentence, actually,
make that two hours,
is said out of context,
there is no way
that the agent can know that the
user is referring to the pickup
time for the pizza order.
The context in this conversation
ensures that your Dialogflow
agent knows that this
request is related
to the pizza ordering intent.
For the pizza example, we
built our agents step by step,
starting with creating
intents, followed by entities,
and then contexts all done
within the Dialogflow UI.
Sometimes you may already
have existing sources that you
can extract entities from--
for instance, a call center
playbook or an FAQ document.
So we look at ways
to leverage this data
when building our agent.
Sometimes all you need is
a conversation interface
to surface answers from the
existing back end systems
and capabilities.
And so we look at deploying
your back end code
as a webhook on App Engine.
We also look at how to
customize your agent's UI,
so that you can have
your own branding.
This is where we deploy a
custom front end on App Engine.
We also want to
secure our webhook,
so it only makes authenticated
calls to the back end services.
In our course, we start with
a pizza ordering example
where the back end is meant
to store pizza orders.
So you're mainly writing
into the database.
Then we move on to
an HR manual example,
where the back is a
knowledge base where
a query will look
up for definitions
and send it back to the user.
So you're mainly reading
from the database.
So how do we build
this knowledge base
in the first place?
We use an employee
handbook, which
is an HR manual document with
topic keywords and definitions.
So all we need to
do is leverage that
to build our knowledge base.
In the hands-on lab, we
use Cloud Datalab Notebooks
to quickly run Python scripts to
extract topics from the sample
HR manual, then push them
into a data store entity using
the Cloud Datastore API.
Next, we use Google's
Natural Language API
to form synonyms of these topics
and add them to data store.
Finally, we call
the Dialogflow API
to then populate your
Dialogflow agent's entity list
with these topics from
the data store entity.
The demo that
follows will walk you
through the steps
covered so far.
So I will pull up
our demo screen.
And I will maximize it.
So I've already done some of
the setup work for the demo
that you would do in the lab.
So I've already created
a Datalab instance.
This is actually a
Compute Engine VM that
hosts our Datalab Notebooks.
So that's already
up and running.
So now, we can preview
our Datalab Notebook.
So I'll go to a Web
Preview and change the port
to 8081, Change And Preview.
And I already cloned
the Datalab Notebooks
that we will need to use.
So the first one that
we're going to look at
is process handbook.
So I'll click that.
And I'll do Clear All
Cells to make sure
that we have a fresh start.
And then I can execute
these cells one by one.
So we'll make sure that we
have the right version of Cloud
Datastore.
Then I'm going to make sure
that that new version gets
restarted.
And now, we can look at our code
for processing the handbook.
So I'm going to run
these cells one by one.
So I'm importing the
Datastore library.
And then this is what will
actually extract our topics
and their definitions from
this HR manual text file.
So I'll run this block of code.
And we can see that
it's extracting
the different headings, which
are our topics, from that text
file.
Now, we're going to do
basically the same thing
with the Synonyms notebook.
So this will just generate
synonyms for all of the topics
that we just extracted.
So I'm opening the
Process Synonyms notebook.
I'm going to clear this
one and do the same thing.
So we'll make sure that we
have the correct version
of Datastore.
And then reset the
session to make sure
that that takes effect.
And now, we will
import the NLTK library
to generate our synonyms.
And we'll import Datastore
in this notebook as well.
So this is going to look
at the Datastore entities
that we already have
named under Topic.
And it's going to use the
NLTK library to generate
synonyms for those entities.
So we'll run this block of code.
And there it goes generating
synonyms for all of our topics.
So this might take a second.
And in Datalab, the
way that we know
that a cell is finished
running is this side bar
will turn from gray to blue.
So that will let us know
that it's completely finished
with that block of code.
So we'll have to wait for that.
Looks like we're getting a lot
of synonyms for these topics.
It should be almost
done, towards the end
of the alphabet now.
And our side bar there turned
to blue, so that one's finished.
So now, we will actually call
the Google Natural Language
API to evaluate the salience
of each of these topic keywords
to determine how relevant they
are to the overall context.
So we'll run each
of these cells.
And this is what will actually
push all of the synonyms
that we just generated
into Datastore as well.
So we can see this is going
through the different topics
and evaluating their salience
in the overall context
of the document.
And so that cell is finished.
So now, we can look
at Datastore and see
how those got pushed
into our Datastore kinds.
So I can go to a Datastore
in the GCP console.
And I see we should
have two kinds.
So we have Topic.
This is all of the
actual keywords that were
extracted from the HR manual.
And then we can switch
over to synonym.
These are all of
the synonyms that
were generated from those topics
and also pushed to Datastore.
So those are all set.
So now, I can go to the
Dialogflow console itself.
And I've already
created my agent.
And when I created it, I
imported an existing project.
So I imported this same project
that I have my Datastore topics
and synonyms in, so that they're
matched up and connected.
And so now that
that is set up, I
can go back to my
Datalab notebooks
and look at this
Dialogflow notebook.
And I'm going to clear this one
just to make sure it's fresh.
And we will run this cell to
install the correct version
of Dialogflow.
And then just for
good measure, I'm
going to do a
restart to make sure
that that gets incorporated
into this notebook.
And then we can
pick back up here.
So this Dialogflow
notebook will actually
take all of the entities
that we created in Datastore
and import them into
our Dialogflow agent.
OK.
So that's done.
So now, I can switch back
to the Dialogflow console.
And I can click on
Entities and create one.
So I'm going to name it Topic.
I'll uncheck Define
Synonyms, because we
did that in our notebook.
And I'll just enter a test
value for now as a placeholder.
So I'll hit Save, so that
it creates that entity.
Actually, I may need to run
that Dialogflow notebook again,
since I hadn't created
the entity yet.
So let me restart that.
So we'll do clear.
And I should be able to just
pick up here and then run
this one.
OK.
Let's check it now and
see if that worked.
So let me refresh here.
And there they are.
So that Dialogflow
notebook actually
took all of these
entities that we
had in Datastore
and their synonyms
and put them in our matching
Topic entity in Dialogflow.
So now, we're going
to look at intents.
So I can create a new intent.
And I'm just going to name
this one Topic as well.
And I need to allow this intent
to be able to be looked up.
So I'm going to create an
action under the intent.
And I'm just going
to call it lookup.
And I'll name the
parameter name Topic.
And then I'm going to connect
it to that Topic entity
that we created, so
it shows up there.
And then the value
will also be Topic.
And for fulfillment, I am
going to go ahead and enable
fulfillment, because we're
going to enable a webhook
call for this intent.
So all of that is set up.
So I'll save that.
And now, I'll add a couple
of training phrases.
So these are what we talked
about in the presentation.
We can start with just a few,
so that the agent can kind of
know how this topic
entity will be
called from the topic intent.
So we can just give
it one or two for now,
so that it gets a quick idea.
So I'm going to say, tell
me about annual salary.
And before I exit
out of that, I'm
going to highlight the
term annual salary.
So I just click and drag there.
And I'm going to make
sure it knows that this
is calling my topic entity.
So I'll hit Enter.
And then I'll add one more.
I'll do, what is discipline?
Discipline is another
term from our HR manual.
And I'll do the same thing
with that topic entity.
So that should be
good to start with.
So I can hit Save.
And you can see this
dialog here popping up
saying agent training started.
So we'll wait for
that to finish.
It should give us a completed
message when it's done.
There we go, Agent
Training Completed.
OK.
So now, I can switch
back to my presentation,
since we have all of
that groundwork set up.
OK.
So this is what we just did.
So now, we can talk
about App Engine.
App Engine is Google's fully
managed serverless platform
as a service product
that allows you to build
highly scalable applications.
The underlying infrastructure
is taking care of for you.
With support for multiple
programming languages,
App Engine enables
developers to focus
on developing their applications
without needing to worry
about infrastructure concerns.
You can deploy your
webhook to App Engine
by running the gcloud
app deploy command.
App Engine will find your
app.yaml file for your service,
read any additional
parameters that you
set, such as version number
runtime and service name,
and deploy your application.
To run your app locally before
pushing it to production,
you can run the dev_appserver.py
command, for example,
to test your Python
app from Cloud Shell.
So in our HR chatbot
example, the webhook
is called by the Dialogflow
agent's fulfillment component
to get answers from Datastore
once a topic entity is matched.
The webhook code
uses information
from the HTTP post
request sent by your agent
to look up the keyword and
match it with the topic
entity in Cloud Datastore.
The webhook will then
return a response
back to the user, which contains
the definition of the keyword
passed in the request.
So we'll go back to the
demos and take a quick look
at the webhook code.
So I will pull back
up my Demo tab.
OK.
And so now the
notebook that will run
is our webhook notebook.
So I can open this one up.
And we'll clear it
just to be safe.
And now we can run
these cells one by one.
OK.
And then this is
what we actually
need to create a webhook for
our fulfillment component
of our Dialogflow agent.
So one way to do this is,
from this Datalab notebook, we
can click this dropdown
next to notebook.
And we could do something
like convert to Python.
So that would convert everything
in this Datalab notebook
into an actual
executable Python script.
And then we could deploy
that to App Engine.
So that's exactly what
we did in this project.
So if I open a new
tab in my Cloud Shell,
and I can look for
that Python script, OK,
so I called it main.py.
Actually, I can look at
this from the Code Editor,
because that will be a
better way to see it.
So I'm opening the Code
Editor from Cloud Shell.
And I have my folder
I already created.
So I'll go into webhook.
And we can look at
the main.py file.
So this is the exact
same thing that
was in our Datalab notebook
we just saw, but it's just
created as a Python script.
So this is how we can
deploy this Python
app into App Engine.
So let me go to App Engine,
so we can see the dashboard.
And we need to initialize
App Engine really quick.
Let me do select an
existing project.
So I'll choose this one,
Confirm Project, Next.
So we don't need to
do this tutorial.
So I'm going to
cancel out of it.
But that should have initialized
our App Engine setup.
So now we can actually deploy
that webhook onto App Engine.
So let me take a
look at the app.yaml.
This is what will deploy
this service into App Engine.
So for now, I'm going to
remove this service name,
because our first service on App
Engine needs to be the default.
So we will take out that
named service name for now.
And let me make sure I'm
still in the right directory.
OK.
So now I can do
gcloud app deploy.
So this is going to deploy
all of our webhook code
we just saw on App Engine--
shouldn't take too long.
So App Engine is
automatically taking
care of a lot of stuff for
us, like updating the service
and setting traffic split for
the service automatically.
So now it is finished deploying.
So I'll switch back to
the App Engine Dashboard.
Let me click on Services.
I'll do a refresh and
see if that helps.
OK.
So now we've got it.
So at this point, we don't
have a UI for our service.
So when we click this, we
won't see anything yet.
It's just going
to say not found.
But we can grab this URL.
And we can switch back over
to the Dialogflow console.
And we'll go back
to Fulfillment.
So up here, I'm going
to enable webhook.
And then I'm going
to paste that URL in
and add webhook at the end.
And then we had already set
the user name and password
for basic auth in
that webhook code.
So I will enter that here.
And then I can scroll
down and hit Save.
So now we should have
a deployed webhook
that's hosted on App
Engine that our Dialogflow
agent is calling.
So let me try.
Tell me about annual
salary, which was
one of our training phrases.
And we see the default response.
So this is the response that is
from that HR manual text file
that we extracted all of the
topics and definitions out
of into Datastore
and then pushed them
into our Dialogflow agent.
And it is calling
a hosted webhook
on App Engine that is
secured with basic auth
on the back end.
So that is the idea.
Let me switch back
to our presentation.
OK.
So a quick recap of some
things we just did--
we added HTTP basic
authentication
to our webhook to prevent
unauthorized access.
And so this ensures that
unauthorized callers
can't call our webhook.
And in the webhook
code, we implemented
flask security framework for
a HTTP basic authentication.
So this requires_auth
method requires
authentication to
access our app.
And we had a check_auth method
which validates the submitted
user name and password.
So these user name and password
values in this code snippet
are what we used in
the Dialogflow console.
And then the authenticate
method sends a 401 response
if authentication fails.
And so we also had to add
this requires_auth decorator
to our handle method to ensure
that the method validates
those authorization credentials.
So besides having a
customized front end,
Dialogflow agents
can also be enabled
in multiple channels in surfaces
from text to voice to phone.
So beyond the web
chat core feature,
which we saw when we tested
it out in the console,
you can use the built-in
feature for deploying your agent
onto any Google
Assistant enabled
device, such as the Assistant
Mobile app or a Google Home
device.
So you can also easily
integrate your Dialogflow agent
into other third party apps,
like Facebook Messenger,
Twitter, and Slack.
And there are also import
and export capabilities
for easily importing
your Dialogflow agent
into Amazon Alexa or Microsoft
Cortana compatible files.
So while Dialogflow gives
you several surface options
from the Dialogflow console web
interface to Google Assistant
to Google Home devices,
these all rely on the actions
SDK for creating the actions
that form your agent.
This allows you to seamlessly
move between surfaces
for the same agent no matter
which platform or functionality
you need.
So a quick recap of our
course and some things
that we just previewed--
conversation is the new UI.
And it's very quickly
changing the way
that users communicate
with businesses, employers,
and others.
We looked at some
of the challenges
when creating
conversational agents that
can handle natural
language input
and discussed how Dialogflow can
address some of these concerns.
And through the life
of a conversation,
we looked at some of
the essential elements
that you want your
chatbot to have,
like intents, entities,
context, and fulfillment.
You also learned how to
define intents and entities
using the Dialogflow UI.
And in the HR
chatbot example, we
leveraged an existing data
source to extract entities
from your Dialogflow agent.
And we learned that being
able to maintain context
is important for the agent to
be able to control the flow
and minimize repetition and
improve overall satisfaction.
And with fulfillment, you
can add functionality,
like connecting to
back end systems.
We then saw the coming
together of GCP products
to productionize your agent,
like deploying your webhook
on App Engine so it can
scale, building a knowledge
base in Cloud Datastore by
leveraging the HR manual,
and using the Natural Language
API to generate synonyms
and adding security.
And then towards the end, we
talked about how you can easily
integrate your agent
into other surfaces,
like the Google Assistant, and
demonstrated some of the newer
additional features.
And one last thing
before we go to Q&A,
remember to claim your
free month of Google Cloud
Specializations on Coursera
for any of our specialization
courses, including data
engineering, architecting,
and developing
applications, and a lot more
by going to this link or
scanning this QR code.
And look for our full length
Building Conversational
Experiences With Dialogflow
course launching on Coursera
soon.
So we are ready
for Q&A. Stay tuned
for live Q&A. We'll be
back in less than a minute.
OK.
So we are back
with some questions
from the audience for
Dialogflow and everything
that we just talked about.
So let's look at
the first question.
We use .NET or any other
development platform.
Can I use Dialogflow
from our environment?
So the answer to
that one is yes.
So the example that I showed
and that we talk about
in the Coursera course
is all using Python,
but that is definitely
not the only option.
There are a ton of different
Dialogflow fulfillment
libraries that are available.
And a lot of them
are already written
and ready to use on
Dialogflow's GitHub page.
So we have .NET, Node.js,
Java, Python, C#, and Ruby.
I think those are the ones.
I don't believe
I've left any out.
But the answer is
yes, definitely.
And then, of course,
another option
would also be just to use
the REST API calls to use
the Dialogflow interface.
OK.
So second question, we have
developed our own specialized
speech to text or use
another third party's.
Can I use it with Dialogflow?
So the answer to
that one is also yes.
Because of that REST
API integration,
you can integrate
your own speech
to text API with Dialogflow
speech to text API.
So that would definitely work.
So I guess we didn't
get any other questions.
So I will go ahead
and close this out.
So I think that's it for
our Dialogflow course.
Stay tuned for the next
session, CETV Machine Learning
101, the What,
Why, and How of ML.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]